Okay,
well,
let's,
uh,
let's begin.
And as you know,
in our class,
one of the topics or themes that we're considering,
it was intellectual history and lurking in the background of course is the big
question of medicine itself and what it is.
What is medical science?
What does it mean to have a medical science?
Well,
this morning,
um,
we'll be considering that.
Is medical science purely the technical application of neutral knowledge or
should we think of it as a cultural institution also built by dominant social
groups in society that in some way may reflect their worldview,
sometimes may embody their prejudices and may promote their interests.
And at least we should ask the question,
if we accept the biomedical paradigm of disease,
what are the implications of that acceptance?
What are the costs?
What are we giving up?
So this,
that's the big issue.
And today what I'd like to do is to look at a subset of the bigger problem.
And this is the medical specialization that's known as tropical medicine.
It emerged in the 1890s
and it period that is of a,
it gained rapidly enormous prestige and influence and is still a major sub field
in medicine.
The discipline thus far has undergone three periods in its history.
The first is the one that we're going to be concentrating on this morning and
that's the period from roughly the 1890s until more or less the first world war
that marks the real heyday of tropical medicine.
The time when it was the cutting edge of medical science,
when it made a series of major,
major discoveries and served the most obvious political purposes
there was followed and its history by a second period that lasts more or less
from world war one until the 1970s or the next half century of tropical
medicine.
And during this period the discipline loses a lot of it's scientific momentum.
Tropical medicine came to be confined essentially to Paris otology and this
period,
the dynamism in medical science moved instead to microbiology and sus offshoots
as immunology.
And that boasted such major developments as antibiotics and a series of
effective vaccines and that attracted the lion share of research funds.
So tropical medicine in the period from the first world war to the 1970s made
relatively few major major discoveries.
Then after World War Two and accelerating from the 1970s we see a third phase
ushered in by such things as decolonization and a new attention to public health
and the third world.
And with it,
a new influx of research funds through the World Health Organization and
powerful foundations like the Rockefeller and Macarthur Foundation's.
Well,
what I want to do this morning is to look critically at tropical medicine.
And by that I don't mean for or against.
What I want to do instead is to look at why it Rose A.
Rose as a discipline.
When it did,
what interests did it serve,
what were its implications?
And I'm going to argue that tropical medicine,
and particularly in this formative early period before the first world war was
clearly socially constructed.
This is a period that coincides with the high tide of colonial expansion.
The age of the scramble for Africa and Tropical Medicine gave expression to an
imperial view of the world and it marked the relationship in medical terms
between Western Europe on the one hand and Asia and Africa on the other,
and between the United States and Latin America as a discipline.
It's served as a major instrument also in promoting European expansion overseas
and American hegemony in the Americas and its applications.
And then the policies that promoted tropical medicine was not only value neutral
science,
it was also an instrument of power.
And we need to bear that in mind.
Now,
the emergence of tropical medicine marked a transition,
a transformation from something that had it,
and that I hope won't be confusing,
but from the middle of the 18th century,
more or less until the closing decade of the 19th century,
there had been an older tradition that can be summarized under the label of the
label of diseases.
Of the tropics and there were a couple classic statements of this older
tradition.
One was a work and important work by James Lind and 18th century physician who
wrote an essay in diseases incidental to Europeans in hot climates and this was
built on the experience of Europeans in the West indies and then there was
another work by James Johnson called the influence of tropical climates on
European constitutions built on the experience of Europeans in India.
Now what these works and other ones of their kind meant in the expression
diseases of the tropics was something particular they meant that in the colonial
world in that is the area of hot climate.
As it was expressed at the time,
Europeans were subject to special diseases as challenges that arose as a result
of conditions peculiar to warm climates and to the resulting conditions of
temperature,
humidity and local ecology.
Under those conditions,
the diseases that would afflict Europeans were not,
however different in nature from those familiar at home,
the diseases of hot countries were heightened in their variance perhaps and the
constitutions of white people.
We're now subjected to new and unfamiliar stresses that made them peculiarly
vulnerable in these climates to disease,
but the issue was simply in the era should we say,
of diseases of the tropics was simply one of kind raw and degree of degree
rather than kind the diseases or the tropics where simply intense variants of
familiar disease processes and there was an educational corollary to that,
which was that physicians who had studied general medicine and European medical
schools were Philly fully equipped to treat the entire spectrum of human
diseases wherever they occurred.
Diseases of the tropics warrant a special category.
There were simply heightened versions of familiar maladies.
In other words,
the concept of disease is of the tropics presupposed a universality of a single
medical discipline that viewed the diseases of the tropical world as posing
problems of degree but not have a thoroughly different kind.
We should also say that this idea of diseases of the tropics already did have
embodied in it some troubling and important questions that had to do with a
colonial or imperial and racial view of the world,
European bodies,
the concept presupposed were different in some way.
For those of Asians and Africans,
they weren't intended for the conditions prevailing in the colonies.
And so the question was where the tropics,
in fact,
inhabitable for Europeans.
You can see this and expressions like darkest Africa,
teaming Asia,
those imply dangerous places and even more the expression of the white man's
grave.
And so the question was whether settling in the tropics was going to be
possible.
Was it simply that Europeans needed a period of seasoning another term of the
time or a climatization after which they'd be stressed,
hardy,
and able to survive in these new settings.
Physicians who dealt with diseases of the tropics thought of themselves as
performing an indispensable service.
One that was useful to European states and especially to explorers,
travelers,
settlers,
colonial administrators,
and of course sailors and soldiers.
The service was to provide assistance and advice during the time of a climate
discussion,
advice on exercise,
diet,
clothing,
and housing.
In short,
everything that new arrivals would need to protect themselves from the rigors of
the new environment,
but the 1890s mark to transition to something different from this view of
diseases of the tropics to something that sounds subtly different but was
profoundly so,
and that is tropical diseases and tropical medicine.
Now,
what was implied in this transition,
this transformation,
it was a vision of the world in which Asia and Africa for Europeans or possibly
Latin America for US citizens were conceived in a really charged fashion as
harboring diseases that were conceptually different from other diseases that
could not be treated by physicians who had graduated from European medical
schools unless they had undergone special postgraduate training.
And the implication to was a different form of hygiene
and there was a work that was a foundational text for this new medical
specialty,
one of the most influential medical works of the whole of the 19th century and
one that had enormous influence on the relations of the metropolitan powers to
their colonial dependencies.
This work was by this men,
a British physician named Patrick Manson who came to be known as the father of
tropical medicine and the work that caused the stir,
what's called and said an enormous fat volume and titled Tropical Diseases,
Emmanuel for the diseases of warm climates and it was written in 1898 which
isn't an accident and it wasn't also an accident that the father of tropical
medicine was British or that Britain became the world's center of the new
discipline Britain at the time being the world's leading imperial power.
Now what were the background conditions that promoted the emergence of this
whole new medical subdiscipline
of first as we said,
was Britain's position as a great colonial power.
There were others as well that lay behind this new medical specialism.
One was something we've already dealt with and that is the germ theory of
disease and the triumph of contagion ism over auntie contagion aneurysm.
The germ theory had a number of possible implications.
One was the idea as we've seen of clinching the concept of disease specificity
and tropical medicine was built on the premise that some diseases lurking and
Africa and Asia now needed new classifications,
belonging and special categories and that to understand them and here was
another of its implications.
You needed physicians who are trained at special institutions and had a
specialized curriculum
and then they could be dealt with by speciphic special remedies and measures of
hygiene that were different from those that had been successful in bringing
about a mortality Revolution in Europe.
Okay.
Now,
as you all remember,
when we examined the theories of mocks one patent coffer,
their germ theory mark the end of an alternative approach to medicine,
one that had flourished at mid century,
particularly in continental Europe,
but was intellectually vanquished by the laboratory methods of bacteriology and
later Paris otology.
This was the idea of social medicine associated with the radical German
physician.
Rudolph your cough for social medicine medicine was a collective enterprise and
what was important for physicians to treat not only individual patients but
society as a whole dealing with issues of sanitary conditions,
poverty,
nutrition,
social justice.
Well the germ theory of disease was a setback for social medicine and I'm going
to argue that tropical medicine one to even a step further and the turn from
that direction.
It argued that in the tropical world,
the tree problem,
and we're talking with the period down to world war one,
the chief problem was to preserve the health of European settlers
as a discipline until much later in its life,
tropical medicine largely ignored the general health of indigenous societies.
This also came to mean something somewhat sinister.
When the logic was applied to the global north and south and black white
relationships,
it seemed to suggest that the bodies of Africans and teaming Asians weren't
medically dangerous,
that they were the reservoirs for diseases that pose serious new threats for
Europeans and there was an implication,
a possible strategy for hygiene and that was that perhaps the best way forward
was for Europeans and indigenous peoples.
To be segregated in their housing arrangements that European should live in the
tropical world and special enclaves where the latest prophylactic measures would
be applied,
whereas natives or indigenous peoples could be left as they had been found.
Alternatively,
if you read some of the literature,
the uh,
produced by works of European right riders such as summer set,
Mon,
you'd see that the Europeans were advised to take to the hills during the
dangerous summer months,
leaving dangerous natives behind,
but we shouldn't forget the tropical medicine at the turn of the century was
also where the scientific action and excitement and medical science we're taking
place beyond the germ theory of disease,
tropical medicine and bodied,
the various latest developments and above all the science,
the new science of Paris otology and it attracted some of the leading figures,
indeed in the development of microbiology to enter this new discipline.
This was true,
for example,
of Robert Kaul who came,
made a voyage to Italy to study Paris Tautology in the form of malaria and then
set off for the colonial world.
Pastor at this time had just died,
but his institute saw affiliates or satellite institutes set up at Saigon at
Tunis,
Algiers in the 1890s all preaching the new discipline of tropical medicine and
pastors most famous enabled discipled Emile grew,
became a specialist in this new discipline.
To understand it,
we need to remember two major breakthroughs.
The first was by Patrick Manson in 1883 at that time he discovered something
that was radically new.
He was dealing with the disease of elephantiasis and he found that the full
aerial warm that causes it is transmitted by mosquitoes.
The first example of a vector borne disease transmission,
this was epic making and not respect and it was also a movement from bacteria or
the wasn't known at the time.
Viruses to more complex life forms.
The interaction of humans with biologically more sophisticated protozoa or
helminths or worms and with insect diseases could now be seen to be part of a
much more complicated process and with complicated life forms.
Then there was following this,
the establishment of the mosquito theory of transmission for malaria,
which took place during the end of the decade of the 1890s with two figures who
are working independently of each other.
But in 1898 established that malaria was a parasitical disease transmitted by
certain species of mosquitoes.
So malaria,
which is a disease that will be dealing with after the spring break was of
decisive importance in the establishment of tropical medicine and malaria was
the disease that was at its heart and its center.
The two people were in Italy,
and we'll be coming back to this in a couple of weeks when we resume classes was
in Italy.
There was Giovanni Battista Good Aussie
who made a very elegant demonstration and very convincing one that,
uh,
human malaria was transmitted by mosquitoes.
And he did so by experiments in which he may introduce just one variable in,
uh,
the exposure during the warm summer months of large populations to biting
insects.
He protected by screening or later by chemical means,
uh,
select groups of people while everyone around them was falling ill of malaria.
They lived in exactly the same conditions as those around them except for one
variable that they weren't subject to bite the bites of flying insects.
And thereby he established that it was indeed insects.
Mosquitoes and certain types of mosquitoes will be returning to that.
Not all mosquitoes,
just Milan unoften lien mosquitoes and certain species of them that uh,
transmitted the disease of malaria.
At the same time,
Ronald Ross,
a British physician in India,
was working in stead with malaria among the Aav,
that is birds,
avian malaria where he demonstrated that it too was transmitted by the bites of
mosquitoes.
And he argued by analogy that human malaria was probably transmitted by
mosquitoes as well.
Now this was the age of a ferocious imperial rivalry and Ross was the first
British scientists to discover the pathogen of a major disease and he became a
national icon.
The British answer to pastor or call,
he won the Nobel prize.
And along with Manson became one of two decisive figures and the founding of the
discipline of tropical medicine.
And it was quite interesting that,
um,
there was an extraordinary collaboration between mountain and Ross in India
where Ross wrote home what he was finding under his microscope in India and sent
that back to Manson who,
uh,
worked with him in suggesting new directions for his research and pushed him
forward.
So in many ways,
the discovery of the transmission of malaria belonged to Manson as well as Ross.
Well,
in any case,
malaria became the template,
the ideal type of tropical diseases.
And in Manson's great work,
malaria occupies the largest amount of space in the volume.
The reasons being that it was a perfect Lee vector transmitted disease,
a perfect parasitic disease.
The plasmodium that causes it,
as we'll see in a couple of weeks,
lives in a closed cycle and never exists free.
And the environment,
human beings don't happen upon it.
And the plasmodium has an extremely complicated life cycle in both men and
mosquito.
And the involvement of the mosquito also is scientifically complicated.
Um,
in other words,
uh,
which useful and important that glossy was a naturalist as well as a physician.
So Paris otology was scientifically interesting and intellectually.
So to study malaria,
ology one needed to be a physician but also an entomologist,
a naturalist,
and to have a knowledge of the basic sciences.
So in nine 1898 for a whole generation,
Paris otology replaced bacteriology as the cutting edge of medical science and
it became the foundation of this new discipline,
the rising discipline of tropical medicine.
Well,
if that's how it emerges,
what is the new discipline?
Well,
Manson defined tropical medicine in his great work.
For him,
it was a special discipline with diseases of an area defined by geography and
warm climate diseases.
There he said we're unlike the diseases of the temperate zone and they require
therefore a special medical discipline to deal with them and they require
physicians who are specially trained in postgraduate institutes.
So for that reason,
tropical medicine emerged outside of established medical schools.
Prerequisite presuppose that physicians needed a special curriculum and training
to deal with diseases that were conceptually different.
For example,
in 1898 in association with Joseph Chamberlain,
the secretary of state for the colonies,
and you can see the role of the state in the promotion of this new discipline,
which was seen as important for the promotion of imperial interests.
And with the collaboration of Patrick Manson,
there was founded the London School of Tropical Medicine with the specific
intention of training.
Colonial medical officers in a new medical discipline or very closely associated
was the Liverpool School of tropical medicine.
Another idea that mountain said was essential to the new discipline was the
tropical diseases were caused not usually by bacteria,
but by more complex biological agents with complex life cycles,
protozoa and helmets,
and that they were transmitted by insect vectors like mosquitoes,
the or the sets.
He flied.
Malaria had pride of place.
It was the ideal time to illustrate this.
And it's the first disease that Manson discusses on his work and the disease.
He discusses it greatest length.
There were others of this type.
Uh,
they're like,
uh,
trypanosomiasis,
which was African sleeping sickness,
which was caused by a parasite awesome.
That multiplies in the human bloodstream and causes skin eruptions,
anemia,
chronic fever,
debilitation lethargy and perhaps coma and death was transmitted by the Tetsy
flaw or there was [inaudible] myosis caused by worms with the snail as it ought
to alternative host or leishmaniasis or yellow fever,
a viral infection.
It was later discovered,
transmitted by a certain species of mosquito.
Well so far,
uh,
if you were reading mountains work,
you would have found the diseases I've just mentioned would be the ones that you
would have encountered and there was a kind of logical coherence to what they
were.
Diseases of places with warm climates transmitted by mosquitoes caused not by
bacteria but rather by more complex life forms.
But Manson then goes on and what we see then is something of a grab bag of
diseases that don't seem to have much of a scientific connecting link.
He mentions certain infectious bacterial diseases,
some of them very familiar to you already.
Bubonic plague,
Asiatic cholera.
He adds leprosy.
He then moves on to certain nutritional diseases.
Pellagra which is caused by a diff,
a deficiency of Niacin.
If your diet consists not of wheat but exclusively of corn or Barry Barry or
certain fungal diseases and even causes calls,
heat,
stroke,
a tropical disease.
Well,
another background factor was institutional,
should we call it the institutionalization of this new medical discipline that
is,
it coincides with the high point of European expansion.
And this wasn't just a coincidence,
it was an important instrument in the,
uh,
domination of African India for instance,
as important as gunpowder,
enabling settlers to run mines and plantations traders to travel administrators
to govern missionaries,
to preach and soldiers to perform their duties.
So for this reason,
tropical medicine rapidly attracts governmental backing,
certainly in the British case and institutional support and assistance from
powerful economic interests with concerns in the tropical world.
So these institutions in Britain,
we've already talked about the London School of Tropical Medicine,
the Liverpool School of Tropical Medicine,
the Royal Society of tropical medicine and hygiene.
And it's embedded in a new major journal,
their journal of Tropical medicine and hygiene founded in 1895 in France.
We see the posture institute in the United States,
such institutions as Johns Hopkins,
the Rockefeller Institute.
And in particular its international health division,
the American Academy of Tropical Medicine,
the American Society of Tropical Medicine.
And in the US there were a couple of distinctive features.
One was the Association of Tropical Medicine with the military,
and it's leading figures,
Walter Reed and William Gorgas.
We're in fact army officers
and it was in the western hemisphere to that yellow fever replaced malaria as
the quintessential tropical disease.
Some of the institutional links can be seen in specific cases.
And example,
that's recently been studied somewhat intensively is the relationship of the
Harvard Department of Tropical Medicine to the colonial establishment of
American power in Liberia.
And in particular the Firestone rubber plantations.
And one can see there the clear role of tropical medicine in promoting if we
like the expansion of company interests to extract resources from Liberia.
This was an important illustration of the uses that tropical medicine Ah,
could be put to,
well,
what were some,
if that's what tropical medicine was as a discipline,
what were some of its implications?
The implications of the world view that it suggested.
One
is that Africa,
Asia,
and Latin America had something in common.
Uh,
this was an artificial construction of European American imagination.
There were seen as reservoirs of disease is that threatened Europe,
Europe protected by the ramparts of civilization and medical science,
so tropical medicine embodied down to a later period.
Certainly in this period down to the first world war or Eurocentric worldview.
It was initially not responsive to specific locations as the tropics where
artificially constructed as some single homogeneous place.
Okay.
The natives of the tropics,
we're also conceptualized as somehow dangerous harboring a vast array of lethal
and highly contagious diseases.
Another implication
was the tropical medicine was concerned for the early in the early decades of
the new century,
primarily overwhelmingly with the help of Europeans,
sutlers administrators' missionaries and soldiers.
There was little concern for the health of the indigenous population.
Indeed,
the medical problems of the colonial world that received attention were those
the threatened Europeans,
not the health problems and the indigenous population.
There was little attention to the social and economic determinants of what we
might today call third world problems,
health of health,
such as poverty,
labor conditions,
malnutrition,
and there was a neglect of major diseases that were often the major health
problems of the local population,
say dysentery or gonorrhea,
pneumonia,
tuberculosis in recent years.
In fact,
the blindness of the past has even resulted in new international attention to a
group of diseases termed neglected tropical diseases that cause large scale
suffering through poverty such as poverty,
low productivity,
poor pregnancy outcomes,
but not for decades were received little funding or attention from policymakers.
Okay.
More ironically,
a major issue not considered after World War One,
as I said,
was the health of an impact of colonialism itself on the inhabitants of the
tropical world.
That is,
there was no attention to the way in which colonialism itself contributed to
environmental degradation or promoted labor mobility and unsanitary conditions.
The way in which it promoted unplanned urbanization,
low educational attainment and poverty.
Yeah.
In fact,
this period,
the first period of tropical medicine from 1892 just after the first world war
was a time,
one of the times of the greatest epidemiological disasters in the tropical world
with virgin soil epidemics like small pox and measles and the impact of what was
called constructive imperialism,
railroads,
roads,
trade,
the transportation revolution all enabled a pandemic of bubonic plague from the
1890 to 1920s and epidemic influenza in 1918 and 19 to occur in the tropical
world as well.
Colonial wars,
the involvement of the colonies in the two world wars had major disease impacts,
so did the ecological impact of railroads,
factories,
mines and plantations,
and the recruitment of migrant labor.
So justice in the case that we examined at greater length in your reading of
North America disease played an important part in European expansion.
Another implication was public health policy in Europe and North America.
Hygiene had given rise to a broad gauge sanitarian movement,
one that reformed urban living conditions through what we might call a in
introducing a new jargon into our course,
horizontal programs of public health.
That is improvements that dealt with living conditions across a broad spectrum
of diseases.
We've seen that in the sanitary movement and the tropics.
Instead,
metropolitan powers apply to different vision of what was called vertical
hygiene or tropical hygiene.
Now,
vertical campaigns of public health targeted instead single diseases,
and they were designed to protect above all Europeans against the most menacing
epidemics.
That was tropical hygiene.
Then something different from what was practiced at the same time in Europe was
one of the implications.
Another implication was a new prestige and authority for physicians.
Ros and Caulk,
for example,
now became advisers to metropolitan governments as did Manson.
It meant also another implication was perhaps what we might call a selective
historical amnesia.
Many of the diseases identified as tropical had only recently been present in
Europe and they weren't eradicated by temperature,
but by broad social and economic improvements.
Malaria itself had been a European disease as you know,
bubonic plague and cholera.
Awesome.
And then tropical medicine was clearly an instrument of cultural and ideological
hegemony.
It was a justification and rationale for colonialism.
Europeans felt that they had health and civilization to offer,
and that medicine was a means of winning acceptance of the colonial prejudice,
uh,
presence.
So tropical medicine provided a narrative of European progress,
rationale,
rationality and civilization,
overcoming ignorance,
superstition,
darkness,
and the witchcraft of natives.
Patrick Manson was very explicit in his vision of the relationship of medicine,
an empire.
And as simple sentence,
he declared,
I believe in the colonization of the world by the white race.
Well,
that was the early period of tropical medicine,
uh,
between 1890,
more or less.
And just other period after the first world war.
Yeah.
Later we see a transformation in the discipline and I don't want to argue that
it's the same today as it was at the eve of the first world war.
Radical radical changes in tropical medicine came through a number of
influences.
One was the second world war itself,
which was in part,
and although there were deep contradictions involved in it,
it wasn't part,
at least a war against racialism.
Um,
the discipline was affected by decolonization.
Okay.
Also by the rise of American hegemony it Germany after World War show with new
priorities.
It was influenced by globalization as an explicit idea and its implications that
we all live in a single disease environment and that what happens in distant
parts of the world or also vitally important for the entire world population.
Okay.
And then there was,
what was very important also was a transformation in funding because of those
factors around then during the 1970s,
the World Health Organization introduced a major new emphasis on tropical
diseases and with it in 1975,
a major new research project.
The same happened with the Rockefeller Foundation in the 1970s and then the
MacArthur foundation there afterwards.
And this meant a new dynamism scientifically for the discipline of tropical
medicine.
And also,
uh,
with that,
major attention are reversing an earlier trend with an emphasis on global health
programs that would be applicable everywhere and that would include major
attention to the health of the population of indigenous peoples in areas would
had been neglected by an earlier phase of tropical medicine.
And so the entire discipline,
if we like,
which transformed after World War II and became something that no longer
embodied a colonial position and no longer embodied,
um,
the idea that it was the bodies of Europeans,
that jurors are privileged protection rather than the health of indigenous
peoples in other parts of the world.
So tropical medicine was a very important instrument of colonial power in the
period down to the first world war,
and it was slowly transformed,
um,
in the interwar period and radically so,
after World War II.
So I hope you'll bear that in mind as you think about the issue of what is,
are the implications of medical science and what are its implications for the
kinds of society and the world that we live in.